[Music]
[Applause]
hey Jess come for you what's happening
I'm really I'm really happy to be here
and to talk to you about a topic that is
very close to my heart today I want to
talk with you about comics and more
specifically I want to show you some of
the great things that I've found on the
internet and how to create comics on the
web and also the lonex that I had when I
tried to create my own very own web
comic and how to make this comment
actually accessible not only for you not
only for some but actually for literally
everyone and this topic is so close to
my heart because let's see my guess and
probably also has many of you here in
the audience I'm a great fan of comics
myself I came in man when I was young I
would go to the comic book store or
maybe like to the corner shop and just I
grabbed a magazine
sometimes even like hardcover comic
books and try to learn more about like
the stories and adventures of my
favorite protagonists and heroes and I
think most of you can actually relate to
this probably everyone can relate to
this don't you think I was thinking back
then when I was so enthusiastic about
comics it would be so cool to become a
comic art myself as you can see things
turned out a bit differently I'm now
working as a software engineer and
building web applications and other
things but I still like to draw in my
free time and I was thinking oh like
maybe I can actually make it a hobby
maybe I can make it like an activity
that I just pursue in my after hours
after work and I can actually maybe
create something so I had a look what
extra options where I remembered from
back in the time that print comics like
the traditional medium of comics as we
already know it for centuries in fact is
something that might be worth pursuing
and I looked what actually the
challenges were that I had to overcome
to do this I realized they were actually
a couple of them that came into my room
as
McArthur's first of all I would actually
have to find a way to publish myself or
maybe find a publisher couldn't actually
get my work out which seemed already
kind of like a laborious process and
then I also realized that when I
actually want to make people aware of
like where my comic is and what actually
does I also have to focus on black print
based marketing like maybe I go to a
fair or maybe like sit down somewhere
like for a six turns around and actually
try to tell people like in person what
this comic is about and last but not
least probably also what you have to go
to this may be like months or a year
long thing where I actually draw
everything hand it in to my publisher
and they edit it and they correct it and
send it back after we edit it until I
actually published my first comic and
this already seemed like a bit but then
I also looked on the other side how does
it actually look like challenge rise for
people who actually want to read my
comic lights on how to actually read us
of my comic interact with this and what
do they have to go back um I realized
that first of all they have to have
physical access to the medium so they
actually have to go down to the book
store or at least they have to go to the
door when the mail order rice pick up
their package at the post office they
also have to carry around the book and
actually bring it with them they cannot
even just I go out with like a whole
library of like comics they maybe take
like a book or two and this is about it
because of portability concerns but
something that really struck me when I
thought about a little bit longer was
something much more significant in fact
I kind of like didn't really consider
that there's this very kind of essential
prerequisite that I have to fulfill when
I actually read a printed comic which is
it actually requires me to have almost
perfect vision I actually require to be
a sighted person to read a comic book
from I don't know everything funny from
Anton house norm read my Mickey Mouse
magazine and this is something that I
found really hard to think about I was
like oh I didn't even consider this
because yeah I lived like as a sighted
person all my life so
I never even bother to think about it
and then after this I was like okay but
actually other options like like how do
you actually comics when you are blind
or visually impaired person and had a
look on the internet and actually found
a lot of like interesting ideas of
people who are already put into practice
or I couldn't imagine even unto this
point people who actually try to expand
out of the original ream of comics into
other fields of sensors one project I
for example found like really
interesting was some that try to explore
haptic sensors and also audio sensors so
people who might have never had the
ability to actually be comics but also
those who might have lost the vision
during the life of time can actually go
back and actually read their favorite
stories again as they used to one of
this projects for example is called life
it's by philip maya and what he creates
is a rail like comic book which
represents all of the illustrations and
all of the narrative in a very haptic
manner so you can explore every single
frame of the story by using your hands
and actually touching the material right
in front of you to understand what's
going on and to understand we are
locally and spatially protagonists are
currently and then also kernel panic is
an interesting webcomic that is written
by Christopher Wright and who makes like
an intentional effort to not only upload
every single image of his comic strips
onto a personal website but also include
right next to it a comic transcript that
can actually be read by screen reader
users once they browse the website and I
think the most inspiring project in my
opinion has been comics and power which
is a comics bookstore created for the
blind by guy Hassan which features
several very popular comic books as well
that are all generated by a single
person in a fashion that creates this
illusion that you actually reading the
comic you're actually putting up the
comic book and reading panel from panel
the texts
but also the sound like descriptions of
any kind of noises and a front is really
cool and looking at this and actually
trying to find out more about like guy
actually picked us to create this very
immersive experience using our generated
comics
I want to try something similar myself
and I really wanted to dive deeper into
what can you actually do with audio how
can you actually untap the potential of
like ordinary sit stories and also how
can you make use of this quite easily on
the web
I knew that screen readers actually
required a straightforward approach
because I knew so many web pages could
actually already be read by screen
readers if it was done right so I
started out in my day-to-day work I
actually work at a consulting firm that
also specializes in helping clients with
proven rates EPS but also amber and so
as this was all very familiar for me I
was thinking okay would be cool if it
was like a JavaScript application with
the EMA tech stack because this
intuitive familiar and also it actually
helps me later on because it's already a
fully fledged singer page application
framework to scale my application easily
with curl release and count maintained
dependencies like data library a testing
solution or also routed solution out of
the box to make it for me easier to
actually make this comic project on lift
because I could know that maybe two
years so now three years from now this
app actually still exists and it should
also work and still be maintainable and
last but not least I also thought it
would be so cool if it was like a proper
JavaScript application because then I
can actually add all this interactivity
and interesting animations for a sighted
user experience there might also be very
immersive and interesting to explore so
looking at this approach there are
comics of power already provided I want
you to also have a very similar user
story for screen reader users for those
that use assistive technologies to
browse the web comic and I first of all
once righted an embedded transcript
I couldn't really think about just like
having the strand slip right next to the
page I actually want to have an
experience that would be similar to
someone actually coming to the website
and reading panel for panel and I also
wanted to include annotation for imagery
not only a translate text so people
actually can get like image of the scene
and last but release yeah I actually
wanted to create this illusion that
there's this inner voice that you have
and you have when you read something and
that's actually what's reading to you I
think it would be really cool to have it
like our generator to actually have like
proper voice acting but for this first
version of this application I really
wanted to just have approach to make it
as easy and as tableau as possible and a
screen reader approach seemed perfect
for me and this storytelling that a
screen reader driven I realized was
actually quite straightforward to
implement once I actually took advantage
of HTML and the powers of area in my
application for example I have these
single frames that you can see here on
the left side here for example you can
see like a person on a boat they're like
on the sea and just also see a speech
bubble saying no and also like sound
word just accent splash right and each
of these images can also be contain a
layer of images so I can for example
have a background image and a foreground
image and all kinds of other text
bubbles as well that are embedded in the
single frame and I knew that to actually
make the whole scene being narrated as I
would see it as a reader I wanted to
have one singer one single description
of it I want to have one single check or
one single label for the screen reader
to actually read so I decided to make
use of like art attributes or area
labels in this case and more
specifically in this case with the area
label and the image role in my
application to actually make sure that
everything that is told in this image
it's also available for screen reader
users
there's also a word of caution though
you can't use area labels when you want
if it's like very necessary if you
realize it really eases your development
effort but using area all over your
place in your application over the use
of using cementec 8l can also be hard
for screen readers to actually read and
therefore they should only be used
sparingly what you can also do if you
know you just have one single image just
like use the alt attribute of the image
tag and then you actually on the best
way to actually implement this because
browsers I actually built in a way to
support this very straightforwardly with
very good support and one interesting
thing I also found with building this
webcomic was realizing how powerful it
actually is to embed checks not only in
an image but it actual HTML because once
I actually do so it becomes the screen
readers and it's available just by
default I don't have to do anything I
just put it there and then it's already
in my narrative and so just like to get
an impression what this actually sounds
like I hope you can try this out I will
also show you how I actually like to
test this later on in my application to
see what's actually happening I like to
use the specific screen I called chrome
walks it's like yeah free screen reader
plugin you can install in chrome but if
it for example a Mac you can also use
voiceover for Windows user that's also
NVDA which is actually also quite
popular screen reader in the blind
community so they're different to choose
from it's just actually your tasting I
think any screen reader you get started
with it's already great for
accessibility testing so let's see how
it goes so this is just a little bit
quiet I think maybe let's try just how
it goes for everyone but can you already
hear something with a rhythm storyteller
here on the stage it's a bit hard to
tell so now we on my website and he I
have like this iframe embedded just like
so we can click here to enter main
navigation style Aeneas chapter 1 there
is a and now with the extra screen we
can navigate
and became travelling interactive
element to the next interactive element
for example heading summer painting to
that also
yeah described by the screen reader and
most importantly each single frame can
actually interacted with as well and you
can actually be read there is a person
in a thick jacket sitting on a boat on
the dark and stormy sea image I'm not uh
I'm not a recognised book author yet but
I'm getting there the boat is rocking
while the waves splash against it image
swoosh splash the waves continue shaking
the boat the person on the boat sitting
in it motionless image and it's really
cool to really see you can have each
single element actually be read to you
by the screen reader and the personal
ability by turning over their left
shoulder their face still unrecognizable
in the darkened half covered with the
hood of their jacket which way and I
found this really impressive this is
something that just comes out of the box
and yeah I actually I don't have to do
too much effort HTML is already on my
side so this is really great let's just
like switch ten extensions term let's
get back to the presentation
[Applause]
so thank you
something I find like super striking
every time I go onto reddit or see like
demonstrations of blind users of vision
plus how they actually interact with the
web is that the zoom feature is so yeah
so obligatory for an experience on the
web for them so being able to you not
only on your desktop but also on your
handheld device to go and tap in and
actually zoom in with your two fingers
is essential what you scientists might
have seen and some applications if you
have rode I'm yeah I'm guilty of this
myself is something like this so this
actually sets the maximum scale of the
whole screen to one meaning you cannot
zoom anymore and this is something you
might sometimes implement because
there's this user request like every
time when I tap into an input field
suddenly the whole page zooms and I
cannot do anything anymore and then you
add this and this issue is fixed but
what it's also introduced is a major bug
for anyone who has like in a visual
impairment and can barely see what is on
the screen because things are too small
or the images are a little bit too
blurry had too low contrast so what is
so essential for actually preserving
this capability is being able to zoom
and not provide this maximum scale and a
friend is so important to no doubt to
actually pay attention to making this
possible font sizes should be legible
use sixty pixel or larger and you're
actually already good to go and also
having like a rich contrast having like
favorably dark color on like a light
background is also planaria me for a
great user experience for anyone who is
visually impaired and in mine comic book
I was sort of thinking old be so cool to
have all these cool fancy animations I
want to have like something that's
really nice I can you for anyone who is
sighted and actually wants you enjoy the
experience so I was thinking okay like I
say anything I actually have to take
care of and in this instance I actually
remembered one very specific incident
which was later called the Pokemon shock
incident and this actually occurred
maybe some of you actually too young to
still know this but
it happened around like 20 years ago in
1997 in December in Japan where suddenly
at like a certain time of like December
the 17th almost semi-matte children were
admitted to the local hospitals and
everyone's surprised was like okay
what's going on because it was happening
all over the country and the kids had
like all kinds of symptoms like nausea
or dizziness some were unconscious some
even had seizures and later on it
actually occurred to everyone that just
a recently a new episode of Pokemon has
been aired on TV it seemed there was a
correlation so the episode got taken
down like the agency were actually
broadcasted the episode went on an
investigation to find out what's going
on and they actually came to the clue
that there's one specific scene that
might have been the cause of this very
adverse effects in so many children all
over the country who watched the episode
so in the episode I won't show the scene
obviously because it's safe but in this
episode that's one particular scene we
can see two different specific frames
I'm just showing the frames which is
totally fine so first of all the
creators of the episode showed a very
bright red frame right next to a right
blue frame in very high frequency
interchangeably for around 6 seconds so
this created a very strong light effect
and in people who have photosensitive
epilepsy or those who are prone to
seizures caused by strobe light effects
this can actually have really adverse
health kind of effects and this is
something that really taught me that
it's so important to also watch out for
this and in regards to strobe effects
also realize that because so many people
actually are out there who don't even
know they have the condition because
they're never exposed to any kind of
lighting like that the only safe measure
that you can take for making sure that
no one gets harmed is not to use any of
these kind of strobe light effects at
all
and this is also when I realized this is
what I want to take care of and that's
gonna lead also to make sure that
animations are not autoplay by default
but can actually be set this way there
are many other things that I as a
developer can actually reassess before I
can say okay this replication is really
now accessible its keyboard
accessibility to actually make place for
screen readers or users who only
interact with the keyboard to go through
the application but also color contrast
semantic HTML are so critical
correct heading irony to actually allow
people who are not decided to navigate
the page and actually explore it in a
very natural way and also landmarks are
one of these things one other aspect I
want to go into is patron allegation
about changeless because many of us are
building these single page applications
or JavaScript applications that have
their very custom routing solution where
a lot of things we don't get out of the
box that you might have had with the
server rendered app and in my
application this was also the case if
like a user for example just like
navigated to another page for example
like to new chapter they wouldn't get
any feedback on the screen reader
instead it was just like happen they
might further explore with the screen
you know what's going on the page and
then they would go like I think I
changed the page but I'm not really sure
not really sure what actually happened I
actually found that in the ecosystem
that I work in there is an add-on like a
plugin that I can stall in my americaís
ssin called MSCI document title that
first of all helps me to update the
document title of an application every
time the route changes this is a pre
requirement for the other solution I
wanted to also have my application which
is called accessibility announcer which
is a simple component I can drop into my
root application template and this
component will then keep track of
changes of the document title we'll
observe this and every time it actually
does change it will make sure that
screen readers pick up on the pin change
and can actually
you feed that back to the user this is
now amber specific but I am very
confident that in whatever ecosystem you
are building an application or be like a
vanilla JavaScript application that's
already a straightforward community
solution for you there that you can also
as easily install and if there's not I
can also highly encourage you to start
building one and maybe ask the community
that you're building in it for help and
interestingly just like getting into the
details of power to make this app
accessible I also want to learn more
about how in general we actually make
apps accessible in a very informative
talk called don't break the web Melanie
Sam know for example goes into detail
how the app is actually not accessible
to some audiences and what we can
actually do to make it better and I
think the most striking number or the
most striking summary I take it took
away from this talk are the falling
numbers so there's been this kind of
survey like this investigation of the
web AEM who actually explored the
accessibility of 1 million home pages
and more specifically of the 1 million
most popular websites and their home
pages thinking that this is some very
first page anyone sees is probably the
page where you put most effort into that
everyone can actually access this and
further navigate from it and also
looking at the most popular ones to
actually have an estimate of ok like
this is actually how people usually
experiments web because these are the
most popular websites everyone Wizards
and if you now look at this pie chart
you can see there's this one number
which is like very large that's 97.8%
and the other one is at around like 2%
and looking at accessibility they want
to find out okay like how many of these
web pages are actually functional and
don't have any accessibility errors it
would be so great if you could say okay
most of them are actually accessible
most of them are functional especially
like the most popular websites it
probably put so much effort into
actually making it functional for screen
readers in all other kinds of assistive
technology
but to choose today still is that these
2.2% that we saw on the chart are the
ones that actually work according to the
web content accessibility guidelines and
the other striking amount of 98% of
sites accessibly vice broken and what
does it mean broken mostly it's a color
contrast issues so someone who is
visually impaired might not even be able
to actually read the checks properly or
explore elements on the first page of
the website it has a lot to do with like
images that are actually information but
don't have like an alt attribute next to
it and also broken links or empty link
tags that for example open up a model
but actually don't lead anywhere and as
a screen reader user you might actually
want to navigate to a link like that but
once they actually hit it you realize
I'm not sure I'm not getting feedback
from the screen reader so what's going
on and honestly it's it's some kind of
work and we have to do something to
actually prove the situation there are
things like XCore for example that we
can install in our test suite to make it
possible to actually automate the
process of testing or applications for
accessibility but also other tools can
help us to get like a better feeling for
it but most importantly I think we
actually have to practice empathy and we
actually have to get like a better
understanding about what the experience
for other people who are not as sighted
as us or not as like motor skill as us
actually experience web and therefore I
would like to encourage you to actually
get a screen reader running and actually
do a real manual accessibility testing
because this is how I actually see it
like if you had like for example a back
like a CSS style bar on your website and
someone was like oh like this is
happening in Firefox and you would also
go like wow I'm gonna reproduce this
back in Firefox I'm gonna have to write
it the fix I'm actually gonna check
manually in Firefox as well if it
actually works
to make sure that it is actually
functional again and I think a similar
mindset also applies to accessibility
testing
a screen reader reproducing what the
page actually does and then most
importantly if you're like a sighted
programmer actually unplug your screen
and actually see what is happening how
you can actually experience website see
if actually elements are suddenly
missing or gone and you cannot find them
anymore
see if you are confused about where the
content that they actually want to
explore right now is and then figure out
what can I actually do to improve the
situation because in the end I believe
it's really about trying to create great
things on the web and this doesn't only
include comics this doesn't only include
art this includes so many other great
things that we already built on the web
and I believe it would be such a great
promise to the future if you can make it
accessible to literally everyone with
that said thank you so much I would also
give a special thank you to guy Hudson
from comics of power who helped me with
extra video on my web application just
for free which is great and all these
great other inspiring accessibility
edits are gleaming about snow and winter
and Melanie Sumner who speaks so much
accessibility if you're interested in a
topic follow any of them I can assure
you you will learn so much and with that
said again thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]